today let's talk about the unique
benefits of magnesium glycinate now as
you may know already magnesium is
involved in over 300 different enzymes
including making energy as ATP including
all sorts of things with your muscles
and the nervous system as well as your
DNA but it's important to understand
that magnesium comes in a lot of
different forms so if we look at what
magnesium glycinate really is it's
really a combination of magnesium and
the amino acid glycine together combined
and when you combine those you get a
much better absorption in the intestine
versus using a type of magnesium that's
not well absorbed like magnesium oxide
or sulfate or carbonate or even
magnesium hydroxide those are all poorly
absorbed but other forms like magnesium
glycinate are very easily absorbed and
magnesium glycinate is very gentle on
your stomach it won't cause the diarrhea
that some other forms can create like
magnesium citrate so it has a much
lesser laxative effect it's good for
overall relaxation
muscle relaxation especially at night
preventing cramps so it's really good
for Sleep improving insomnia and it also
is good for improving energy now it's
not going to keep you up at night but
it's going to allow you to get into a
much deeper sleep to have energy during
the day magnesium glycinate also has an
effect as a vasodilator so it's really
good for blood pressure it's also good
to help regulate calcium and prevent
calcium from accumulating because
magnesium and calcium work together and
since it's involved with calcium it can
also reduce the risk of kidney stones
and it's also been known to help
increase insulin sensitivity to help
blood sugars and people that have
problems with insulin resistance which
could even be a pre-diabetic or even a
diabetic magnesium glycinate also has
been known to help people with migraine
headaches and states of lower mood like
depression and anxiety so it's a really
good form of magnesium that overall
helps reduce stress now if you get this
as a supplement I would try to get one
that also has a vitamin D3 and B6
because both of those nutrients will
help the absorption even more and
sometimes people have a question of
what's the difference between this
magnesium glycinate versus magnesium bis
glycinate well there is no difference
they're this exact same supplement so by
adding that little bisque behind the
name does not change the chemistry at
all now since we mentioned magnesium
citrate I will say that's a really good
one for leg cramps at night it's a good
one for stress it's a good one for blood
pressure but magnesium citrate can
create a laxative effect so it might be
better for people that have a tendency
to be more constipated but if you
compare the two magnesium glycinate is
just a little bit better for various
reasons it won't create a laxative
effect and magnesium glycinate is not
dependent on the pH in other words you
can take it on an empty stomach or with
food you don't even need a strong
stomach acid to absorb it which is
unique because most minerals need that
strong stomach acid so as people get
older and they lose their stomach acid
they're not going to absorb minerals but
if you take magnesium in the glycinate
form it will be absorbed regardless of
the pH of your stomach now the best time
to take this form of magnesium would be
right before bed because it's going to
help you sleep it's going to relax you
it's going to prevent those leg cramps
however if you take it to other parts of
the day it's not going to necessarily
make you tired it's going to just make
you feel more relaxed should you take in
an empty stomach it doesn't really
matter you can take it with meals or
without now the normal dose I would
recommend would be anywhere between a
hundred milligrams to 400 milligrams per
day and that would depend on what kind
of problems are you trying to solve do
you have severe muscle cramps let's say
you have severe high blood pressure or
you have sleeping problems well just
take a little bit more but if you don't
take a little bit less like I said
before magnesium glycinate is a
combination of magnesium and glycine so
now let's talk about the benefits of
glycine it creates a calming effect it
will help you sleep it helps the
neurotransmitters in your brain thereby
increasing cognitive function it's even
good for collagen support and blood
sugar control and sometimes it's used as
an anti-inflammatory because it can help
get rid of inflammation it can even help
improve bile production okay which can
help your absorption especially of fats
it's also related to increasing energy
just like magnesium so you just might
find that your energy starts to increase
over a period of time and lastly it's a
precursor for something called
glutathione to help you detoxify now
another form of magnesium that a lot of
people are taking is called magnesium L3
and 8. that specific type of magnesium
is a bit more expensive but it's a
little bit better for your brain so if
you're trying to take magnesium for more
cognitive improvements then that would
be the form that I would recommend are
there any side effects for magnesium
glycinate and there's really only two
that I found and one would be low blood
pressure but you'd have to take a lot of
it over a period of time and you might
end up with a lower amount of blood
pressure so this might be good for
someone with high blood pressure but
it's not going to be significant it just
might be a little bit lower than it
should which might be a good thing
because it causes this vasodilation
effect which actually will increase
circulation the other thing about
magnesium glycinate is it does tend to
interfere with certain medications so
you want to check with your doctor it
can inhibit the function or the
effectiveness of certain medications but
as far as the laxative effect it's not
going to create much of a laxative
effect as other types of magnesium but
that also depends on your dosage if
you're taking a lot of it with all this
magnesium from the food and maybe in
other supplements it could contribute to
more of a diarrhea situation in which
case you're going to have to kind of
reduce the dosage from one of your
supplements or this one specifically now
where do we get magnesium from the diet
primarily it is involved in chlorophyll
it's at the heart of the chlorophyll
molecule that's that green stuff in
Plants as in leafy green vegetables the
chemistry of this green chlorophyll is
very similar to the chemistry of our own
blood but with some very unique
differences so with chlorophyll we have
this magnesium that tends to be on the
green side and then with blood we have
iron which is on the red side but one of
the best sources of magnesium is just by
consuming enough leafy greens as in
salads and other leafy greens so even if
you took three cups of dark leafy green
vegetables every single day you would
probably get the amounts of magnesium
you would need as the recommended
amounts
but of course you have to realize that
you're not going to absorb a hundred
percent of that it's going to be a
portion of that so you might need to
have more but my point is that the rdas
for magnesium for men is roughly about
420 and for women is about 320. that's
just the amount of magnesium that you
need to prevent a deficiency but not
necessarily the therapeutic dosage that
you might need if you have a severe
imbalance
and one of the problems with magnesium
as far as testing it in the blood goes
is you're not going to be able to really
detect a magnesium deficiency because
the majority I'm talking about 99 of all
the Magnesium is inside the cell not
outside the cell in the blood so a blood
test is not going to give you a lot of
information you'd want to do what's
called an intracellular magnesium test
and I will put a link down below for
that information magnesium is also in
other Foods as well it's in fish it's in
nuts like cashews so I hope you now know
more about this magnesium glycinate it's
a fascinating supplement that has huge
benefits and there's a lot more to know
about magnesium if you have not seen my
other video of magnesium I put that up
right here check it out